es ist eine alien sonne das ist keine
wissenschaftliche sondern eine
journalistische analyse jedenfalls wenn
wir unser exklusiv interview mit
professor am loeb einmal auseinander
nehmen dann spricht eigentlich alles
dafür dass es sich um einen von einer
intelligenten spezies gefertigt das
artefakt handeln muss zwar hat sich auch
bei solchen analysen auch die
wissenschaft schon gehört aber es sind
einfach sehr sehr viele indizien die
einen natürlichen ursprung ausschließen
und auf ein künstliches objekt schließen
lassen
und sie passen zusammen jetzt also die
analyse bei pixum science fiction hier
gibt's täglich hochspannendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen professor luc verfasser der
studie über das interstellare objekte
moore war bei uns exklusiv im interview
er hat dort die these vertreten dass es
sich bei dem ersten entdeckten
interstellaren objekte in unserem
sonnensystem um ein künstliches von
einer außerirdischen spezies gefertigtes
objekt handeln könnte mir tragen die
fakten zusammen und kommen zu einem
ziemlich klaren schluss wenn die
wissenschaft etwas besonders schönes
oder klares entdeckt dann gegen
eigentlich immer alle davon aus dass ist
gelten muss dunkle energie und dunkle
materie sind so ein beispiel
die erklärungen sind alle schlüssig und
schön niemand zweifelt in der
wissenschaft an ihre existenz allerdings
steht der direkte beweis noch aus
niemand hat partikel oder sonst etwas
gefunden was diese dunkle energie oder
die dunkle materie sein könnte trotzdem
gibt es nur wenige die zweifel anmelden
und genauso ist es beim uhr immer mehr
forschungsergebnisse sollten in die
richtung eines künstlichen objektes und
professor abram loeb hat eine idee um
was es sich handeln könnte
das hat mich dazu gefahr anlass die
möglichkeit in betracht zu ziehen dass
es vielleicht ein ein lichtkegel ist und
wenn ja wurde es künstlich hergestellt
und dann stellt sich die frage wer hat
das getan und ist das eine fremde
zivilisation
aber was spricht dafür dass nur ein
solches licht segel sein könnte und da
ist die studie von apple im laub und
schmutz bioly bahn brechen
sie haben nämlich eine mit einem
natürlichen objekt unerklärliche
eigenschaft von humor entdeckt das
objekt hat beim vorbeiflug an der sonne
so stark beschleunigt wie es für ein
natürliches objekt
unmöglich ist jedenfalls wenn es nicht
wir über einen kometen zur ausgasungen
kommt es gibt einige berichte dass nicht
viel hitze wahrgenommen wurde
es gibt eine begrenzung wie warm dieses
objekt war
dies bedeutet dass es sich um einen sehr
guten reflektor handelt und es kein
guter absorbiere des sonnenlichts ist
interessanterweise bewegt sich dieses
objekt jedoch in einer flugbahn die
nicht nur durch die schwerkraft der
sonne geformt wird
es wirkt eine zusätzliche kraft mit sehr
hoher bedeutung in der regel für kometen
kann die verdampfung von eis auf der
oberfläche des kometen einen
zusätzlichen schub geben
das ist was ihm den anschein eines
kometen gibt aber es gibt keinen kometen
schwanz bei diesem objekt und wenn es
vom kometen einen zusätzlichen schub gab
die ausgasung dann hätte diese ausgaben
durch die spinn periode des objekts
verändert und das konnten wir nicht
feststellen
und noch etwas ist paradox und mit einem
natürlichen objekt unerklärlich es hat
eine form die viel extremer ist als
jeder assault oder comet den wir gesehen
haben und wir können das sagen weil es
sonnenlicht reflektiert und da das
objekt nah an der erde vorbei gekommen
ist konnten wir feststellen dass es sich
alle acht stunden dreht und dass sich
die helligkeit um etwa den faktor 10
ändert was bedeutet dass es mindestens
fünf mal länger ist als breit
es wäre also wie alle abbildungen zeigen
extrem lang und starb für mich eine form
die wir so noch nicht in unserem
sonnensystem jedenfalls natürlich
gesehen haben nur wenn wir raumschiffe
bauen haben sie unter umständen diese
form und es ist extrem dünn jedenfalls
ist nur dann die beschleunigung durch
die sonne erklärbar wir schlugen vor
dass das sonnenlicht nur durch den
strahlungsdruck auf dieses objekt
einwirken konnte
damit dies effektiv ist muss das objekt
sehr dünn sein
weniger als einen millimeter dick und
eine größe von etwa 20 metern haben
wenn es andere intelligente spezies da
draußen gibt dann ist humor für
professor luc nichts besonderes mein
ansatz dazu ist dass wir so viele daten
wie möglich vom himmel sein müssen
ich spreche aus bescheidenheit ich denke
dass wir nicht besonders sind wie wir
wissen dass ein viertel aller sterne an
planeten wie die erde hat ungefähr so
groß wie die erde
mit der richtigen entfernung damit
flüssiges wasser an der oberfläche und
die chemie des lebens wie wir sie kennen
bestehen kann
und wenn man für ein viertel aller
sterne so und so oft würfel milliarden
mal dann ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass es
primitives leben gebracht und mikroben
aber vielleicht auch intelligentes leben
da draußen und wir sollten nicht davon
ausgehen dass wir die antwort vor der
suche kennen wir sollten aufgeschlossen
sein ich denke dass wir nichts
besonderes sind ich denke dass wir
existieren ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass
es andere zivilisationen gibt und es
gibt noch ein indiz dass gegen ein
natürliches objekt spricht wenn es
nämlich natürlich wäre müsste es
unerklärlich viele solcher objekte geben
vor etwa zehn jahren schrieb ich einen
artikel in dem versucht wurde vorher zu
sagen wie viele asteroiden natürlich
gesteine das sonnensystem von außen
erreichen werden und wir haben das um
einen faktor von einer million bis zu
100 millionen geschätzt
irgendwo zwischen 100 und 100 millionen
weniger objekte als nötig den ursprung
von humor zu erklären
dieses objekt gehört also zu einer
klasse von objekten die weitaus größer
ist als wir auf grund von asteroiden im
sonnensystem erwartet die frage ist also
politisch selbst wenn es natürlich ist
wissen sie könnten wir etwas neues über
die umgebung lernen in der es produziert
wurde und ich denke das wäre faszinieren
ich denke wir sollten aufgeschlossen
sein das ist mein grundlegender punkt
dieses objekt wir spricht also der
vorher von betroffenen annahme wie viel
solche objekte es im interstellaren raum
geben könnte es ist also als natürliches
objekt extrem unwahrscheinlich trotzdem
will er sich als wissenschaftler nicht
festlegen aber schließt die möglichkeit
einer alien sonde explizit ein und
spricht von einer realistische
möglichkeit nein ich würde sagen es ist
eine möglichkeit die auf dem tisch sein
sollte und ich würde es als eine
realistische möglichkeit neben einem
natur
den ursprung betrachten und im interview
mit professor gibt's noch mehr fakten
die für ein künstliches objekt sprechen
den link zum video gibt es hier einfach
draufklicken und wenn er auf keinen fall
videos bei pixum verpassen wollte zu
diesem und allen anderen themen
dann abonniert klicks um auf englisch
hier einfach draufklicken dann da gibt's
auch videopremieren wie das
exklusivinterview mit dem harvard
professor luc zum beispiel und tier ich
mache mal hier hin da geht es weiter mit
werwolf no big bang wir sehen uns
hoffentlich auf dem kanal auf dem
englischen kanal von pixum stay tuned
und csu